servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video mit und wir haben
heute für euch eine saftige challenge
soll die alles oder nichts challenge die
habe ich mir so ein bisschen in
zusammenspiel mit euren toter
vorschlägen ausgedacht und zwar wie nie
bevor wir eine kiste offen ja musst du
dir dein eigenes equipment anschauen und
dann sagst du entweder rüstung oder
waffe und du darfst die kisten uhr luden
dann werden mal ein besseres item als
als du selbst hast drinnen ist also wenn
du sagst rüstung und was eine leder
rüstung darfst du die kisten nur luton
wenn du eine goldressource kiste hast
wenn du sagst waffe und thorsten
holzschwert dazu die kiste minuten wenn
eisenachs steinzeit oder so weiter drin
ist weißt du kriegst der kirche alles
oder nichts und wir probieren jetzt
belegen los macht jetzt auch nicht sagt
was ist die erfahrung ist ersten kiste
ich habe immer lust den eigentlich ist
größten bio zwei gold bugs eine gold
testen gold schwarz alles klar die die
ok ich sagen können ich sage erste kiste
waffe oben gewesen
da darf nicht lauten dass nicht-juden
euro etwas und ich sage rüstung an die
partie relativ kurz ich bin der
trendigsten kister goldbarren goldmünzen
besser als leder bis 22
der rüstungs werten her aber diesen sind
besser oder willst du sagen jetzt nicht
besser wenn man geht dann schon da also
ist ein besseres material
aber fakt ich sag wieder durch und holt
hose goldhelm also wir haben jetzt wenn
du zum beispiel eine mixed rüstung hast
du sagen wir dort palais der pott gold
dann zählt der part der quasi auch in
der kiste ist weißt du alles klar und
ich sag jetzt ist wieder rüstung
das war richtig lag jemand und ich
glaube ich sag jetzt waffe und nicht
taxis nicht besser als gold wert
okay aber ich hab nur ein rad verloren
ist nicht so genau
wir können auch sagen später wenn wir
merken dass wir dass unser equipment
vielleicht doch zu gut wird dass wir
sagen okay wenn wir falsch raten werfen
wir mal machen
mal schauen wir dann sehen aber spd
folgt werden zu spekulieren wir wirklich
schon über rüstung hast dann das soll
die chance nicht mehr so wenn du sagst
es ist ein eisenteil drinnen und du
sagst einfach rüstung und es ist dann
gerade 1 wo du schon was fast so gut ist
dann ist das ein problem das problem ist
jedoch schwierig ist einzuschätzen einer
rüstung so ganz krass durch mixed ist
ich glaube aber ich bin lieber nicht
beim fünf module eigentlich ist schon
ein steinschlag waffe und und dein
schwert und 210 mio
lucky es fraglich dürfte bis jetzt auch
jede kiste öffnen glaube ich an dem
letzte modul war gar keine
und ich sage waffe nein es ist keine
waffe drin
grafing tablets fleischmann weil die
kiste wo das essen nicht nur pforten
man will so sechs module weiß nicht was
ich dazu sagen würde ich bin ja nicht
weg ist aber dann auch eine sechsseitige
rüstung es muss irgendwas sein
es muss endlich schon fast ein lucky
bester reiter die sich auf was junge du
legst dich gegen anfangs dass sein
springen immer schön lacken okay was sag
ich rüstung leute muss rüstung sein
es ist rüstung lederhose und es eine
change your lederhosen chain roses drin
und einstein schwert also rüstung und
waffen war richtig gewesen
sehr gut ich war bisher zu machen mit
mit rausschmeißen weil ich bin okay
alles klar leute wenn wir ab jetzt
falsch raten dann müssen wir das dass
das alte muss wir selbst haben
wegschmeißen also wenn ich jetzt mal
gesagt ich habe hier chain hose sieht
sich mal an wenn ich ihnen sage
rüstungen und es ist noch eine chain
hose drin
dann muss ich meine eigene chain hose
wegschmeißen also meinen teil der nicht
besser ist als eine kiste und ich sag'
ich sag rüstung ich muss rüstung sagen
leute ich hab schon stein shirt und
gestand ich muss eigentlich auch was zu
sagen klar gesagt es wäre viel essen
drin alles noch eine steinachs cover
jetzt tatsächlich tatsächlich eine chain
hose drin aber auf einen helm der besser
als mein goldhelm ist was muss ich
machen jetzt kiste aufgemacht rüstung
gesagt das musst du gehen gar kein
einziges tags muss da noch dann musst du
eine rüstungsteile von ihr werk werden
wird mal eine leggins weg meine nichten
nicht putz oder sowas sagen
nach dem wasser
ich hab manchmal die blockade lockern
sei das schlimmste was zu sagen ja da
muss aber leute ich kann euch jemand
coolen tricks zeigt und zwar ist hier
oben in dem dispenser eisenwaren drin
bei der rakete in module acht sein
scheint wenn du ganz oben das beide
rakete dann springt noch nicht auf den
block dann kann ich jetzt sagen muss ist
ein spiel angeschaut
was muss ich trocken chain nicht so
unternimmt man die schuhe die schuhe
alles da aber ich darf die kiste nicht
genau sagen ich bin so tono alltag
ausrüstung ja mein gott habe ich
abgeräumt
junge mann gerade eben einfach einen
test und alle plugins mitmischen können
junge asset wie sie fertig ich dass ich
will so das ding
das jump secret erklären du bist oben ja
ja ich denke mal die spitze von raketen
dispenser geht mir bitte dass eisenberg
manager will ich die chance habe muss
ich die kiste noch blut in die muskeln
er muss sich kisten absoluten ich bin
eigentlich zufrieden mit meiner crypt du
musst du musst die kisten auf warendorfs
keine kiste auslassen ombudsmann und
aber ich kann mir ich kann mir zumindest
mal die die akkus am ende holen sieht
ganz gut aus und ich sage für die letzte
kiste leute wo ich mir sage ich rüstung
bitte rüstung jawohl jawoll junge ich
hatte keine hose und keinen jazz page
und ich hab eine eisenbahn schutz ohne
chip bekommen jungen schönen und guten
hat anleger zu spät aber ich hab mir
jetzt echt mal kurz den arsch gerettet
wie gesagt all black shadow und mich
jetzt richtig setzt aber ich kann mich
erholen
was gibt alter schwede ok krass ich habe
halt leider keine angel
das heißt wir sind hände gebunden er
hatte lange daran ich bin allein die
hände geangelt herget oft vollkommen das
ist locker nicht etwas macht der junge
der gibt richtig komische hits
schau dir mal diesen ecksberg stelle
anders der die hitze angucken aber das
ist ein typ der mich ganz aus dem wasser
raus bislang geglaubt ihr jetzt ein
gesammelt die jetzt von diesem black
lion finde ich richtig komisch wenn ich
einen turnaround mache dann hat er
irgendwo eine aura und schlägt nicht
sehen das nicht normal dass ich noch mal
geht voran
jetzt bin ich fit man ich würde da
zuschauen
ich muss ich konstatieren ich bin ohne
eine echt aufgeschmissen
ich bin ohne angel nicht überlebensfähig
leute seht ihr das black shadow und wie
findest du jetzt da kommt nicht ran
gerade habe ich auch nie mit dem bogen
mal oder seiner arbeiten auch nicht in
der lage die hole ich mir endlich mehr
läuft kann das match etwas gemacht er
hat nämlich erwartet so in der erde
hattest du langgezogen angeles als
center hatten wir auf aufgetan katja es
hatte gerade gemacht was gegen der cello
ich sehe auch blätter hier ne also denke
ich mir lieber da unten leute alter
schwede
scangos evra hat ist hier ende hoffen
sagt mir was denn secret da ist er
wieder
dazu das ist sieht nicht so normal
außerdem machte ich gesagt man ist immer
noch im wasser kann denn was will ich
auf keinen fall gegen die cap das ist
richtig ekelhaft der folge alle manchmal
auch nagel
ich habe auch nur eine weisheit nicht
wie für rüstungs punkte hat er
zweieinhalb 56 punkte ich habe sieben
einhalb also von der rüstungs punkten
her soll ich mir den holen ok jetzt
jetzt der final showdown
aber klar wenn ihr gegen den
vermeintlichen hacker wir schauen uns
jetzt an aha klingt halt nur noch im
wasser na ja aber da gibt es ein ganz
guter einkommen muss also wenn der papst
dazu standen ist gleich weg gestorben
dann kann minuten und es ist nicht mein
team und ist nicht mit ja oder ja geil
erleichtert ich bin ich bin immer und
immer mit pfeilen unterwegs ich hasse
diese map so sehr wollen baut man ist so
viel wasser ist primitiv sei die kästen
gleich den nächsten chat dahinter die am
op rechte bessere team war ich lass ich
lass das passiere nicht lassen konnte
ich lass dich hochkommen ich kann die
fans alter you say that used as you say
me er kommt ja jetzt richtig durch die
durch den pavillon ein halb herzen oder
1 oder einheit wieder die libro alter
aber junge wie klosters mal vor ich
hätte in der die letzte kiste nicht
richtig beraten hätte einfach keine
ahnung bekommen bei tot gewesen leute
lippe roni all das was von diesem video
endlich gefallen hat unbedingt weniger
checken und in die kommentare schreiben
wie alt ich bin